my father's odd guy and uh he sat me
down
and he said uh I think my mother told me
need to talk to him oh I had three older
sisters I was the only boy
so she said you need to talk to him
and what he told me was
he said when you have sex with a woman
you need to make her desire
you
so you enter her he just skipped all the
like how it works he just said you enter
her a little bit you touch just barely
touch her
and then you come out and you and you
withhold he was Mexican and he had a
weird sort of traditional
he'd say and then you and then you make
her beg and beg and then you go in again
and you go only a little bit and then
you just come out again and you you keep
withholding and until she can't stand it
and only then do you really penetrate
her and she'll come like a rocket like
he was just he taught me how to make a
woman come he wasn't wrong right he
wasn't wrong but I think you need to
tell a little kid some other [ __ ] first
before you get to like how to make a
middle-aged woman come yeah yeah you
know what I mean yeah but that's what he
was like he was very narcissistic and
you know wow
yeah I uh who taught you it's about sex
I mean did you ever I'm asking the same
question a mentor but yeah thanks for
asking man my dad well my dad was 70
when I was born so my dad was an older
guy yeah and so he um
he would always tell me he had dated
chicks grandmothers that were like in my
class and stuff like that and he would
show me like poems that he had written
and they were like on paper that was
like disintegrating like it was like it
was also he was teaching you about
romance yeah my dad was more of a
romancer that's nice so he was teaching
about romance but nothing about sex one
time I saw him he I think he had cancer
somebody was walking down the hall and
like
I thought he was going to have like he'd
had a new girlfriend and we were at her
house she had a nice house and she made
all this like beef brisket or whatever
I'd never even seen it you know blew my
[ __ ] mind yeah just what what your
were your parents married they were
married till I was seven and then they
got divorced and did he have kids before
with other women yeah okay he had three
other children okay so he's now so now
you're how old I'm maybe at this point I
was probably 12 and you saw him
somewhere and he had another girlfriend
yeah
you'd only ever had baloney and call it
concerts oh I've never had brisket no of
course not I mean I was
yeah never even I never even couldn't
imagined it and then
um
I he was walking down the hall and I
thought he was going to like have sex
with us at night time and I would sleep
on their living room on the living room
couch and then he literally uh
he was sick and he defecated all over
himself and it was like one of the
scariest again craziest things that ever
happened because I remember watching him
and thinking well
my dad's going uh
like be with this lady you know and she
was like wealthy and I don't even know
why she even liked us but she did and
then he was sick you know and then I was
so afraid to try to go to help or
anything because he was like
he had cancer and he was getting real
sick I didn't know wow but it was that
anyway that story took kind of weird
term but yeah dude that's just life you
know but yeah it was like a moment where
there was just a lot of life but so uh
one interesting way you put it is you
say what she didn't know why she liked
us so you and your dad were like a unit
you were like a team like so did when he
left when your mom and when your mom and
him divorced you went with Dad no I
stayed with my mom but I always felt
like my dad was just more loving yeah my
mom has like kind of like an emotional
kind of autism like she can't show you
affection kind of that's hard yeah and
um a lot of parents like that it's hard
is there yeah yeah
so it was just kind of like but she's a
hard worker and stuff but anyway it was
uh so then and I was kind of infatuated
by my dad because nothing he did he was
older so everything was awful little it
didn't make sense
um and it was kind of I think it was
more fascinating you know being around
him yeah I felt that way about my dad a
little bit because he wasn't like any of
my friend's dads he was a strange guy
who's a Mexican and um
yeah it was a bit like you European
Mexican you know there's a lot of
different kinds of Mexicans
um I lived there until I was about seven
oh nice um but uh but yeah he was weird
so I kind of like I was fascinated by
him but I he didn't show much interest
he I just remember him always looking at
his eye level like he didn't look down
at me much I just always looked up at
his face and he was looking that way
wow what is that do to you well it's uh
hard
but I feel more bad for him because he
didn't he was alone up there I didn't
think about that I do now because he's
you know very very old and in a chair
like this and he's alone no you know we
don't go see him much me and my sisters
yeah and my mom I mean when she was she
died and in her last year of life when
she was you know we were like there and
kept her in our houses and kept took
care of her until the last second she
had us all around her never alone
because she just was a a loving person
and she you know you wanted to be with
her oh wow but my dad was all [ __ ] up
in his own head and he was you know I
mean narcissism is like a it's a
sickness yeah and it's isolating and
it's very sad you know I feel bad for
him now I'm able to feel bad for him
because he was um it was painful to be
his kid you know physically and mentally
so
um but I'm past that 55 years it takes a
long time to you know were you surprised
how long it took to get past that kind
of stuff because I find it's interesting
a lot of audiences like kind of guys
that kind of like are fit still figuring
things out it's kind of like a lot of
late bloomers yeah I think and no
judgment to any of the listeners but
um yeah I think a lot of young men are
stuck in this time where it's like yeah
we're fake it's almost like you're
figuring sheer it out your parents [ __ ]
out it's like it's almost come to like
this kind of like curve in the pipe
where it's like we gotta kind of figure
this [ __ ] out in here yeah I think
that's right and I think uh
it's hard I don't think you can rush it
I don't think I think it happens later
because something comes loose it just
does it's nothing you can figure out
it's nothing where you can go oh I mean
you think about it once in a while some
and also you spend a lot of Life
avoiding it right so like my when I was
a young dad and stuff I just pushed my
dad away I just didn't want to think
about him so I just decided he doesn't
matter anymore for years and like when I
was little I remember he was spanking me
once which is now to me a really odd
thing is a man's hand spanking that
[ __ ] bare ass a little bony I can't
fathom it now yeah put pants
what are you doing it's really gay and
weird and upsetting yeah but uh I
remember being spanked so [ __ ] hard
like it was it was like blackouts but
like I can't handle this and I remember
thinking to myself I think I was about
nine I thought the day I get a wallet
like oh that was the magical thing the
day I get a wallet with that money in it
and cards and that set of keys the
second I have that I ain't never gonna
look at this person again in my life I'm
getting away from this guy as soon as I
have those that's all you need
so you had a lot you were really you
were really yeah I really didn't like
being around him and my mother divorced
him when they were when I was 10 so then
I had a lot of years just with Mom where
he was around and he would ask for
attention sometimes and I didn't I
wasn't afraid of him anymore but I but
he made me uncomfortable I didn't like
being around there's a lot of good
things about my dad and I I owe him a
lot
um yeah totally you know and he hated
you he did and he also devoted a lot of
life to you know he was a Mexican and he
his our family Mexico they do okay and
they have some influence and they have
you know he had a better life there but
he moved to America it's sort of the
opposite of most immigrants that he went
from Mexico where he was pretty well
established to America where he had no
tools to survive and where he didn't get
the culture but he did it because my mom
was the strong one in the family my mom
worked really hard and she she raised us
and and supported us so uh so he he is
picking my mom instead of somebody in
Mexico and that's how I got to be in in
the land of opportunity yeah it's
interesting yeah it's interesting man
how that a lot of times it's our a
previous generation had to kind of take
an L they had to like really that's
right so you think you could have it you
know it's hard to imagine imagine that
in your own life I'm gonna do something
shitty yeah oh I'm gonna move to Toledo
so my son yeah [ __ ] you kid good good
luck I'm gonna do something I'm gonna go
to Vegas and just keep trying to win
yeah I'd rather sell my ass on the
internet yeah [ __ ] that take my chances
but I I then I so I went through years
of like not wanting to think about them
and then I once in a while I would check
in with him and see maybe we have
something and he'd feel the same and
like I don't want it and he didn't even
seem interested sometimes and that was
shitty
um but then and my mom meanwhile took
care of him she after they divorced she
kept because he was kind of a mess and I
learned from that from watching my mom
do all the way to the end you know my
mom when she was dying she provided for
him and stuff and I learned about her
from that and I asked her about it I
because because she had no reason to be
with the guy anymore they had been
divorced since I was 10 and now you know
this is a few years ago
and she said I want to send a message to
him with she's leaving him some money
she said that he's I want to send him a
message that he's not alone in the world
now that I'm gone
somebody gives a [ __ ] about him
and because that's a that's a promise
she made him when she married him and
even though they divorced she's she's
still honored that promise even though
he didn't stay to his side or whatever
and so that helped me like I was a that
was a
that was a role model for me my mom
later in life and then after she died I
was about to say left uh after she left
after she left me by ceasing to breathe
that's great and some guys probably
think that yeah [ __ ] you Mom yeah I
needed you [ __ ] after she died my
sister and I who were were at her uh
Memorial we had for her and he came and
neither of us had seen him for a long
time and we were talking we were
standing in a room talking about we we
should uh
um where we gonna put him so we don't
have to be near him and then he walked
up with a cane and we were both like
[ __ ]
come here and we sat with them and then
we had this interesting affection for
him because Mom is gone she would have
wanted us to be good to him and he was
so weak
and he was so and I just felt bad for
him and I felt a tenderness for him so I
go to see him once in a while in this
place where he lives and last time I saw
him I just let I let go of everything it
just all went away and now I just feel
this tenderness but I just feel so sorry
sorry for the guy
I'm all that's left all anger and guilt
all those bad feelings they burn away
with time they all burn away completely
and so I'm just left with who's I sort
of fascinated by him now I look at when
he talked he struggles to talk and I
look at his face and watch it struggle
you know and I feel I feel for him you
know anyway long answer sorry